hi BBA students today we're going to
cover topic four which is on uses of
genetic engineering and the
specification point that you need to
know here is to evaluate so to be able
to look at both and the good so the
advantages and disadvantages in this
case the benefits and the risks of
genetic engineering and you need to be
able to refer both of those things to
the context of modern agriculture but
also in medicine okay so we're going to
start off and by just looking first of
all at the benefits okay so for example
and if we look at the first thing which
is going to be in agriculture so farming
essentially crops can be genetically
modified to be resistant to herbicides
so remember resistant meaning it doesn't
have an effect anymore or it's stronger
than and herbicides meaning chemicals
that are that will be able to kill
plants okay so what that means then is
the farmers can spray their crops and
what will happen is it will kill all of
the weeds without affecting the crop
itself okay so first of all making crops
herbicide-resistant okay and remember
that herbicide is a chemical that kills
weeds okay so that would herb sounds a
bit like something to do with plants
okay but it's not the good kind of
plants okay so if farmers are able to
spray this on the crops what will happen
is a really big benefit is that it will
increase the crop yield and therefore
the farmer can sell a lot more of these
product if we have a look at the
benefits of genetic engineering in
medicine one of the main things that you
would have learned about in genetic
engineering is the example of insulin so
there's many other many medical benefits
and but obviously in that one they use
bacteria because bacteria reproduce so
quickly so they would use bacteria which
can make the protein insulin okay and
refer back to the genetic engineering
video to see how that gets done and
other things that can be made is also
other useful proteins so not just
insulin but other useful proteins for
example antibodies okay and what they
can do is they can use those antibodies
in diseases such as arthritis cancer or
even multiple sclerosis okay so I'll
just put that as MS okay and some time
in the future scientists even believe
that they can use the benefit of of
genetic engineering in organ
transplantation but we're not quite
there yet
now as with anything things can be
sometimes beneficial but you also need
to be able to evaluate and to justify
what the risks are to do with genetic
and
nearing so first of all because we don't
yet know because it's so new in science
what all the consequences are yet of
using genetic engineering but there are
some concerns that when they are when
genetic engineering is used in living
organisms
that perhaps the organism may not
survive because we just don't know what
sort of adverse effects may happen and
alternatively the organism may suffer
from health problems and then again this
is sort of the medical context if we
then think about how that is affected in
in agriculture is what might happens is
the transplanted genes so let's say for
example we've got a herbicide resistant
gene can be picked up by weeds and so
essentially what will be created is
something called a super weed so we're
essentially that weed is going to be
resistant to being killed and that's
going to have an effect on the on
animals in food chains and that could
even have an effect on our house as
humans okay and that sums up the topic
of genetic engineering